mmm la journée de grand-mère était à la tête du
tournage de Rock Paper Scissors
que nous visitons pour la semaine où nous passons
un bon moment Je voulais passer du temps avec
toi depuis si longtemps ouais je ne t'ai pas
vu maintenant que l'heure du coucher de cette heureuse année
ici est 9:  30
vous deux ne devriez pas sortir de votre chambre
après être parti bonne nuit
c'est quoi
tu sais j'ai un journal où j'ai des
idées de films qui me viennent si je suis
dans un train ou si j'étais tu sais te réveiller
et j'ai une idée ou je vois quelque chose
qui va ooh c'est plutôt cool
et j'essaie de les garder et on ne
sait jamais quand ils vont devenir un
film mais cette idée que j'ai eue il y a quelque temps comme il y a
12 ans et j'ai écrit  dans un
journal je savais que c'était quelque chose de spécial
mais je ne savais pas quand j'allais
faire un si petit film d'accord j'étais comme
un si petit film et vraiment et quand j'y ai
pensé comme la fille plus âgée
faisait un film  de l'expérience alors c'est
vraiment vraiment j'ai vu comment le faire comme un
petit film et pourtant ça pourrait être très
très puissant  rful et intense pourriez-vous
nettoyer le four pour moi Becca
entrer jusqu'à l'intérieur
mmm Becca elle l'a fait avant
vraiment ne me vendez pas à l'extérieur faites ça d'
abord je serai rapide oh ça prendra juste
une seconde je ne pense pas à  mes films en tant que
films har, vous savez, je sais que c'est le
film d'horreur et je vous ai fait connaître
certains films qui font peur,
mais je ne pense jamais à mes films comme des
films d'horreur, vous savez que ce sont des thrillers,
des thrillers psychologiques et  Je vous savez
que le genre d'un thriller axé sur les personnages
est, je pense, illimité,
vous savez que les films qui ne sont que leur seule
intention sont uniquement d'être une balade effrayante, c'est-à-dire
ceux qui ne sont pas vraiment
intéressants pour moi alors et pop un
accouchement  chaîne je savais que nous allions
avoir son appel alors juste des gens bizarres hé
sage Estonie à la volonté
salut papa
fahza um il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas avec
Nana et pop-pop donc juste vieux
je suis juste propre ici ce qu'il y a dans le
hangar ici je  besoin de savoir psychologiquement
ce que nous faisons et j'ai besoin  de savoir
émotionnellement ce que nous faisons ce que nous
visons afin que chaque scène soit une
variation sur ce thème, donc quand vous regardez en
arrière, tout est une question de
pardon, soit essayer d'obtenir le
pardon, soit ne pas pardonner
et et ce que cela fait pour  la famille et
comment cela cause tant de douleur quand vous
ne le faites pas et donc c'est définitivement comme
chaque film que je pourrais vous dire, vous savez que je suis
vous connaissez Six Senses sur la communication
et c'est sur le pardon